[Applause]
[Music]
for me Webster can hum a tune and now we
no girl can also work a red carpet I
love it dad Travis Scott and Mama Kylie
Jenner are seasoned pros but check out
their one-year-old daughter stormy
making her debut at her very first red
carpet event the little one rocked a
colorful matching set but her best
accessory that adorable smile stormy
looked happy and too cute for words as
she posed for photos with her parents
Papa trav even snuck in a sweet smooch
on her cheek the fam stepped out to
support Travis at the premiere of his
upcoming Netflix documentary called
Travis Scott look mom I can fly where
we'll see the rapper's rise to fame
you can try this any special dish I
always knew it was just the process of
getting everybody else to feel it up
we'll also see appearances from Kylie
and yes
stormy the adorable family has been
living it up all summer long they
traveled to Europe to celebrate Kylie's
22nd birthday and stormy even went with
her mama squad to Turks and Caicos to
celebrate the launch of Kylie skin in
July
Kylie posted this video Travis sharing a
sweet moment with his baby girl
[Music]
Kylie gushed in the caption quote she's
got the sweetest smartest most special
little soul
[Music]